honestly before you had the stroke your
health was pretty damn good right
that's the crazy thing i was in the best
shape of my life that's what james said
he said
this guy worked out religiously lifting
weights i mean you looked at him you
think he's indestructible
that was actually the problem is i felt
between you and me i was working at a
crossfit and did
a super heavy deadlift like personal
personal they were going personal best
heavy in so you're doing a deadlift i
was doing a deadlift
and um at one point saw stars so what
actually happened
was i i tore a cardigan right side of my
neck
which then led to
eventually it threw a blood clot and hit
the right side of my brain and
took out the left side of my body well
this this freaks me out because i'm a
hypochondriac at times and like
the thought of like going you know you
want to go a little more weight you want
to put some muscle on your body and it's
just like
you're pushing too hard you didn't i
mean were you going harder than you ever
thought you'd
like it would cause any issues no no but
in fact the um
the weight up until i put on more weight
was was fine like i knocked him out
really easily so yeah i can put a put a
little more on then it just
something went wrong and i don't know
what it was and no symptoms by the way
no like were there things leading up to
the i know you were like at a film
festival somewhere and
actually the night before i am while in
the screening of the movie
as it was ending i experienced like the
worst pain which headache my life like
a nice pig in the back of my head just
reading and i could not shake it no
matter how much animal i took
so that was the only symptom which i
wouldn't think it's not a stroke symptom
i mean now i i've come to understand
that if you ever say i've had the worst
headache headache in my life you go to
the hospital
doesn't that sort of i mean i know that
when things like i've had a lot of
surgeries and things like that
but you know if like god forbid i had a
heart attack or a stroke or something
like that
isn't it is it always in the back of
your head that you're like
uh oh i should worry about that i had a
headache is it bad enough to go to the
hospital is it
are you like on top of it are you still
not as uh
crazy about it like uh for me yeah
headache-wise no like this was this
headache was like one i've never had
before
i was when i was yeah i was in the
middle of it so i couldn't like go i
couldn't just
drop what i was doing to go to the
hospital all right so let's rewind i
don't want to start with that that's
sort of what you kind of might end with
perhaps
you